vi kazadi bonjour j'imagine que ce
reportage de nos confrères de france 2
fêter quoi ce que vous avez vous même
vécu parce que je précise pour nos
téléspectateurs vous étiez en ukraine
juste avant cette invasion russe vous
avez donc vécu ses premières heures de
guerre ces premiers jours de guerre aux
côtés des populations civiles quand
est-ce qu'ils allaient réagir et on a
croisé certains de nos confrères de
france 2 qui sont dans ce reportage
c'était vraiment la stupéfaction les
premiers jours je suis arrivé avec
abdallah malka william parsons un jour
avant l'invasion de l'ukraine ordonnée
par vladimir poutine quand on est arrivé
le mercredi 7 qui elle vivait
normalement les restaurants étaient
ouverts tout fonctionnait normalement le
lendemain le visage de la ville de la
capitale avait radicalement changé
les sirènes retentissaient constamment
fallait se mettre à l'abri bien
évidemment et c'était forcément la
stupéfaction personnes à qui elles ne
s'attendaient à ce que vladimir poutine
ordonne cette invasion à grande échelle
si on peut dire dans différentes zones
du pays oui les gens s'attendaient à ce
que peut-être ils envahissent l'est de
l'ukraine la région du donbass mais pas
tout le pays pas avec cette force même
s'il faut bien le préciser
les ukrainiens se bat bien mieux qu'on
ne l'attendait et ralentissent la
progression des russes mais dès les
premiers jours on voyait les chars
russes en phase avec les troupes russes
s'approchait dangereusement de kiev et
on avait bien sûr l'écho des autres
combats dans le reste du pays et puis au
fil de vos rencontres et de vos
reportages clovis vous avez croisé la
route d'un certain sergei on le retrouve
d'ailleurs dans l'un de vos reportages
oui absolument quand on était à kiev
bien sûr il y avait les détonations les
explosions les tirs la tension avec ces
saboteurs russe césar ses hommes russes
infiltrés qui arrivait en amont des
troupes russes pour préparer le terrain
si on veut dire et quand on est parti de
kiev eh bien on a essayé on a il ya des
barrages partout donc c'est très
compliqué de quitter la ville c'était
dangereux comme tous les journalistes
c'était assez compliqué seulement parce
que toute façon il y avait des
explosions constamment on arrivait dans
des villes qui venait d'être attaqué
notamment des dépôts de décence ou
par exemple la vigne à l'aéroport qui a
été visé juste après qu'on soit passé
sur le chemin du retour on a rencontré
donc sergei qui était un personnage
vraiment touche on était dans un petit
hôtel perdu au bord d'une route très peu
de personnes les gens étaient étonnés
qu'on arrive savait pas pourquoi il y
avait des des étrangers donc les y avait
eu des forces ukrainiens qui sont venus
voir un petit peu qui on est et c'est
qu'on croit sergei qui est de kiev enfin
sa famille vient de la frontière à
belarus donc en première ligne a vu les
troupes russes entrent et en ukraine
mais lui à l'époque de la guerre et ils
vivaient à kiev il est sorti très
rapidement quand les combats ont
commencé et là on l'a rencontré à 30 km
de la capitale et cherché à retourner à
kiev et je lui ai demandé pourquoi tu
fais ça il m'a dit qu'il voulait
apporter de l'aide des vivres des
médicaments aux gens piégés là bas parce
que tout le monde avait quitté à la
capitale et je lui ai posé la question
est ce que tu es prêt à prendre les
armes pour tuer des russes voilà ce qui
m'a répondu
ma conviction c'est que je n'ai pas le
droit de tuer un autre homme
mais si les russes entrent pour
s'emparer de kiev je ne sais pas comment
je réagirais nous sommes une nation
différente un peuple différent dans nos
esprits et dans nos âmes s'il vous plaît
les russes ne nous attaquez pas s'il
vous plaît
et j'ai des nouvelles le sergei il
acquit à ville en train d'aider comme il
peut à distribuer des vivres etc
quand on a continué notre trajet on est
allé à la frontière moldave et là on a
vu énormément de familles des femmes des
enfants en pleurs qui laissaient leurs
maris leurs frères les hommes derrière
qui eux étaient appelés à combattre les
russes ils n'ont pas le droit de partir
ils sont l'un pour rester pour combattre
les russes on a rencontré un homme
hagard le regard un peu perdu
ou très triste forcément je
l'interviewais on lui a posé quelques
questions et vous allez très vite
comprendre pourquoi il était dans cet
état regarder à la frontière madoff
hier j'ai fait passer ma famille en
moldavie et moi je vais devoir repartir
a donné pro je dominais
qui doit attendre qu'on m'emmène combat
à travers
puis-je être ma famille s'est vendu
cette année en roumanie en allemagne
départ ils vont essayer d'avoir le
statut de réfugié pas où tu tu
vois la triste est un peu de peur aussi
dans son hangar là on est en train de
travailler un petit peu sur un reportage
un peu plus long qu'on va diffuser la
semaine prochaine peut-être pour les
trois semaines de l'invasion où vous
allez retrouver ces témoignages des
reportages qu'on a et tourné notamment
défendre kiev à tout prix qui sont sur
les réseaux sociaux et sur le site de
france 24 et donc on est en train de
travailler sur ça avec des lames al
khawaja europe parsons diffusera dans
quelques semaines alors quelques jours
quelques jours quelques jours merci
beaucoup clovis merci d'avoir